[Musik]
rund um europa werden sie beschlagnahmt
die oft 500 millionen euro teuren
yachten der russischen oligarchen und
seit beginn des ukraine krieges tun sie
alles um sanktionen zu entgehen
auch in israel dorthin kommen sie nicht
übers meer sondern mit ihren privat jets
aber warum fliehen immer mehr
ausgerechnet nach tel aviv und jerusalem
antworten im russischen viertel
jerusalems alex tänzer ist mit seiner
familie vor 50 jahren aus kiew nach
israel eingewandert ist experte für
russisch israelischen beziehungen wie
schiri der oligarch mit jüdischer
abstammung kann nach israelischem recht
staatsbürger werden davon machen fast
alle gebrauch und solange sie sich hier
aufhalten macht ihn niemand probleme wie
sie in europa oder den usa hätten warum
ganz einfach wenn sie sich als
israelischer staatsbürger je nichts
haben zuschulden kommen lassen und kein
internationaler haftbefehl gegen sie
vorliegt hat israel keine handhabe gegen
sie
cookies ag von der liberalen
tageszeitung haaretz recherchiert die
machenschaften der oligarchen seit dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion ihren
zustrom nach israel hatte erwartet man
hat sich hier schon immer gefragt ob
israel einmal ein zufluchtsort für
oligarchen oder ihr dreckiges geld
werden wird und jetzt mit dem ukraine
krieg stehen sie unübersehbar im
rampenlicht
der vielleicht prominenteste roman
abramowitsch der berühmte ehemalige
inhaber des fc chelsea in israel bekannt
als nicht uneigennütziger philanthrop
unmittelbar vor kriegsausbruch versprach
abramowitsch eine sogenannte
strategische spende von dutzenden
millionen dollar an jad vaschem
jad vaschem die nationale gedenkstätte
die erst vor zwei jahren beim holocaust
forum auch wladimir putin als ehrengast
eine bühne gab hatte anfangs kein
problem mit dem geld dass alle gleichen
im gegenzug bat sie laut medienberichten
den us botschafter in washington ein
gutes wort für abramowitsch einzulegen
und von sanktionen gegen ihn ab zu sehen
und daran hält an jad vaschem gespendet
um es tatsächlich zu unterstützen oder
um seinen namen weiß zu waschen mit
hilfe der israelischen regierung jad
vaschem ist schließlich ein arm der
regierung das ding stank zum himmel
aber in dem moment als internationale
sanktionen gegen abramowitsch erhoben
wurden blieb jad vaschem nichts anderes
übrig als auf die zig millionen dollar
zu verzichten sorry mein herr ihr geld
ist dreckig und solange sanktionen gegen
sie und andere oligarchen vorliegen
können wir solche spenden nicht annehmen
doch die gelder fließen weiter ins land
nicht nur journalisten auch liberale
politiker sind besorgt auch roman bond
mann stammt aus der ukraine
er warnt vor den milliarden abramowitsch
gegen die laut einem
untersuchungsausschuss stellt eine der
fabriken von abramowitsch stahl für
panzer her die jetzt auf dem
schlachtfeld in der ukraine kämpfen
die stahlfirma hat die vorwürfe zwar
zurückgewiesen aber das vermögen von
abramowitsch bleibt an vielen orten
eingefroren
diese gelder werden sorgfältig
aufgespürt ein großteil liegt im westen
in europa der schweiz in england und es
ist schmerzhaft zu sehen dass israel
sich nicht an diesen sanktionen
beteiligt trotz des drucks aus europa
und den usa
in israel führt dieser druck der
sanktionen zu einem regelrechten boom
markmann anlageberater für betuchte
kunden aus der ehemaligen sowjetunion
berichtet seine geschäfte seien seit
kriegsbeginn um das zehnfache
angestiegen
russen kommen nach israel weil sie angst
haben dass die ganze welt sanktionen
gegen die verhängen könnte und ihren
geschäften finanzielle schwierigkeiten
machen könnten selbst wenn sie nichts
mit dem regime zu tun haben gegen das
erschien oder sogar in der opposition
sind und was heißt überhaupt oligarch
wenn ein russischer kapitalist oligarch
genannt wird dann sind auch
amerikanische kapitalisten mit
beziehungen zur regierung oligarchen da
ist das gang und gäbe nur dass sie dort
nicht so genannt werden
die meisten israelis sind skeptisch
gegenüber solchen netzwerken vor zwei
jahren waren sie gegen den damaligen
premier netanjahu und dessen
korruptionsaffären mit großkapitalisten
zu hunderttausenden auf die straße
gegangen
kleinstadt prime minister nannten sie
ihn wegen seiner deals mit israelischen
und amerikanischen konzernen und
milliardären in israel sind viele
menschen sehr empfindlich wenn es um
korrupte beziehungen zwischen super
reichen geschäftsleuten und der
regierung geht in genau diese kerbe
stoßen jetzt die oligarchen oligarchen
die dem regime in russland nahe standen
kommen plötzlich nach israel und manche
haben schon lange beziehungen zu den
politikern ihr das mögen die leute
überhaupt nicht das geld von putin nahe
stehenden oligarchen wie abramowitsch
oder viktor wechselberg fließt nicht
erst seitdem ukraine krieg nach israel
und nicht selten in die
rüstungsindustrie
der heutige verteidigungsminister benny
ganz hatte bevor er in die politik ging
vor vier jahren eine ki startup firma
für geheimdienste hauptinvestor viktor
wechselberg erst als die usa sanktionen
gegen den oligarchen verhängten gegen
die firma bankrott heute beklagen viele
dass israel den oligarchen freie hand
lässt
die russisch sprechende gemeinde in
israel sagt fast geschlossen was israel
tut reicht nicht israel muss wesentlich
schärfer handeln wir können schlicht
nicht mehr untätig zuschauen wie diese
gräueltaten in der ukraine verübt werden
aber wir haben noch nichts offizielles
von der regierung gehört und das sollte
sich meines erachtens ändern zum einen
aus grundlegenden moralischen gründen
aber auch was das ansehen israels in der
welt angeht
und so werden in europa und den usa
paläste vermögen und yachten der alle
gleichen beschlagnahmt und eingefroren
während israel putin und seine
oligarchen schalten und walten lässt
[Musik]